autre et reste le problème de la peine
de remplacement à la peine capitale dans
l'éventualité de l'abolition c'est un
faux problème dit robert badinter s'ils
ont le visage seulement sous l'angle de
l'exemplarité de la terreur comme
actuellement la peine de mort on se dit
elle fait peur elle est horrible dans
qu'elle fait peur par conséquent elle
est dissuasive elle est utile et lors le
raisonnement se poursuit si on l'abolît
il faut qu'on trouve quelque chose qui
terrorise
de la même façon alors inévitablement on
est amené à inventer une forme de peine
qui terrorise qui launay tonnes et on
retombe exactement dans les mêmes
erreurs qu'à propos de la peine de mort
alors je ne peux pas croire qu'il y ait
un espèce de confusion de manipulation
je dis simplement c'est la constante
dérives et ses partis de l'idée que ce
qui est important dans la peine de mort
saison voire de dissuasion or nous
savons que ce n'est pas vrai et on veut
de la même façon rétablir une peine qui
soit dissuasive et on se paie recevra l
usage que ce n'est pas vrai alors le
problème de la sécurité des français lui
passe évidemment par une réflexion et
des solutions autres mais une réflexion
d'ensemble et des solutions qui
devraient être comprises
ça c'est là le véritable objet du débat
on vit sur les années d'un code pénal
qui remonte à napoléon 1er bon les
comptes est aussi un deuxième argument
en faveur de peines de mort c'est ce que
j'appellerais le prix du sang le
certains appellent ça la vengeance
d'autres disent la punition la longue le
talion est le talon tally relevé un
stand mort chez celui qui d'un seul coup
et soulevé par la passion de ce que l'on
appelle la justice immédiate
oui ça c'est une angoisse humaine
formidable et c'est en effet l'exorcisme
mais ça c'est ce dont précisément
justice comme la nôtre s'est libéré et
vous savez nous sommes pas différents
des eaux je dire nous appartenons à une
civilisation commune nous français au
sein de l'europe occidentale
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes les
derniers pourquoi